these days it seems like almost every
disney movie is a sequel
prequel or spin-off of some sort sadly
though
some projects from the house of mouse
have never had a follow-up hit in
theaters
but why this is why these disney movies
never got a sequel real steel was primed
to be franchised material long before it
even hit theaters
and sure enough in april 2011 news broke
that screenwriter john gaytens had been
hired to pen a script for a real steel
follow-up this development
was confirmed by the first movie's
director sean levy who also said he
would be back to direct a sequel
however he did note at the time that it
would be a challenge to work real steel
2
around hugh jackman's busy schedule
since then
jackman has been consistently busy which
has helped to keep real steel 2
on the sidelines another issue
surrounding a potential sequel
is the struggle to crack a good script
levy said in september 2014 that he and
jackman remained enthusiastic about the
real steel universe
but that they weren't rushing into
anything either he explained
hugh and i would only make it if the
plot feels fresh but also the character
journeys feel fresh
and we found both but never at the same
time
further complicating matters is the fact
that the original movie was a product of
distribution agreement between disney
and dreamworks
that deal ended in 2016 meaning that
sequels to movies like real steel are
pretty low on the priority list for
disney these days
as far as franchises go this one could
be a swing and miss for levy
and jackman after who framed roger
rabbit became one of the biggest movies
of 1988
another movie seemed pretty much
inevitable and sure enough
disney fully intended to release a
prequel to the iconic semi-animated
crime movie
over the next few years the studio went
through multiple iterations of what a
roger rabbit prequel would look like
these included the tune platoon which
would have seen a young roger rabbit
enlisted into world war ii there was
also a separate roger rabbit origin
story entitled who discovered roger
rabbit
which would have been a musical set on
the streets of broadway
despite these efforts a slew of constant
problems kept the sequel from coming to
fruition
for one thing roger rabbit producer
steven spielberg had a strange
relationship with disney and the studio
needed his approval to get any future
movies off the ground
the biggest issue however turned out to
be the film's budget when it was
revealed the follow-up project would
cost over 100 million dollars to make
disney put it on the back burner in the
years since
crew members associated with the
original movie have expressed their
excitement over the sequel's script
including director robert zemeckis
however
they've also mostly expressed pessimism
over whether disney will end up
producing it
in 2016 for example zemeckis said
the current corporate disney culture has
no interest in roger and they certainly
don't like jessica at all
i'm not bad i'm just drawn that way
ever since christopher reeve's superman
franchise first kicked off
superhero movies have almost always
gotten at least one sequel
they've only become more expansive in
the current landscape too
with modern superhero movies often
spinning off into massive multimedia
franchises
still they don't always warrant a
follow-up take disney's kid-friendly
superhero movie sky high for example
the premise concerning teenage
superheroes attending a high school
exclusively for superheroes seemed ripe
for further exploration in sequels
and according to sky high director mike
mitchell there were indeed plans to
carry on the story in another sky high
movie the second movie would be called
save you and was supposed to take place
in a college setting despite the cast
and crew's enthusiasm however
the movie has yet to appear and it's
almost entirely down to financial
reasons
disney was unimpressed with sky high's
box office which amounted to a solid
83.1 million dollars worldwide
but came up short compared to 2005's
bigger hits
this led disney to abandon the franchise
for the time being
and while the first movie's writer mark
mccorkle has said a sequel could
eventually appear on disney plus
it doesn't look like it'll happen
anytime soon
lizzie mcguire single-handedly launched
hillary duff's career back in the early
2000s
and the 2003 movie adaptation turned out
to be a hit
too grossing 55.5 million dollars on a
17 million dollar budget
in the wake of the lizzie mcguire
movie's success it would have seemed
like a no-brainer for duff to return for
a sequel
however less than a month after the
lizzie mcguire movie first hit theaters
duff announced that not only would this
sequel not be happening but that she was
parting ways with disney
altogether at the time a spokesperson
for disney confirmed that daft's
departure had immediately killed off
plans for the lizzie mcguire movie too
they said we gave them a very generous
offer and unfortunately they passed
hillary is a great girl and we truly
wish her the best of luck
sam raimi's 2013 adventure movie oz the
great and powerful was a spiritual
prequel to the wizard of oz
set in the sprawling world that l frank
baume penned in his original novels
total have a feeling we're not in kansas
anymore
and it looked like bombs mythos was set
to expand even further when a sequel to
raymie's movie was announced a few days
before
the original hit theaters unfortunately
the movie's production faced a daunting
challenge
right from the get-go after raymie
himself announced his total disinterest
in helming a follow-up movie
remy explained in an interview i was
attracted to oz the great and powerful
story but
i don't think the second one would have
the thing i would need to get me
interested
it didn't help that oz the great and
powerful wasn't a huge smash at the
overseas box office either
especially compared to disney's other
live-action fantasy movies
on top of all that os star james franco
has received multiple accusations of
sexual misconduct in the years since
oz's release the chances of an oz sequel
were dicey
enough to begin with but franco's
numerous controversies make the
prospects of a follow-up
even more unlikely edgar riceborough's
original john carter novels
spanned numerous installments officially
there are 11 books headlined by the
character
so it's natural that any movie
adaptation of burroughs universe would
lead to at least
a sequel or two that's exactly what john
carter director
andrew stanton had planned prior to the
release of his 2012 epic too
in fact stanton had ambitions for an
entire trilogy of john carter movies
these plans had gone far enough that the
week of the original john carter's
release producer jim morris revealed
that stanton
and screenwriter michael chabon were
pinning a screenplay for a follow-up
but the first movie's hugely
underwhelming box office performance to
a tune of a 200 million dollar loss for
disney
guaranteed that moviegoers wouldn't be
returning to the world of barsoom
anytime soon two years later stanton
took to twitter to give john carter fans
a glimpse at what could have been
by revealing the titles and logos for
the unmade
john carter sequels gods of mars and
warlord of mars
stanton wrote could have been cool had
big plans
planes fire and rescue the follow-up to
2013's cars spin-off planes
debuted in theaters in the summer of
2014 despite being one of only a handful
of animated kids movies dropping that
season
it turned out to be a huge box office
disappointment and made far less than
the original plains movie
nevertheless disney wasn't planning to
let this franchise go without a fight
in august 2017 a new entry in the
plane's franchise was announced which
was set to take the whole saga
into outer space aside from that however
the project's details were kept
tightly under wraps disney never
revealed the movie's title
nor did they give a clue as to whether
any original cast members would be
returning
all fans knew was that this cosmic 3qual
would hit theaters on april 12
2019 but the untitled planes movie hit
some turbulence it just couldn't shake
in the summer of 2018
when its animation studio disney tune
studios was shut down
with the closure of disney tune all
projects at the studio were cancelled
and any hope of rescue was likely dashed
when cars 3
underperformed at the box office the
preceding summer for now at least
it looks like planes three will remain
firmly grounded
by the early 2000s disney had created an
assembly line of direct-to-video sequels
for its animated movies
starting with 1994's the return of jafar
the
studio released animated sequels to
everything from lady ants the [ __ ]
to the lion king so it should come as no
surprise to find that plans were put
into place to produce a sequel to
treasure planet
director june falkenstein was hired to
direct the project which would have
followed jim hawkins
and his exploits at the royal
interstellar academy supporting
characters from the first movie would
have returned
and the project even got far enough
along to cast willem dafoe as the film's
villain
a nefarious mechanical pirate named
ironbeard
unfortunately the monday after the first
treasure planet
opened in theaters falkenstein was told
that the movie's disastrous opening
weekend had spurred disney into sinking
this sequel
she later said this was a huge bummer
because we thought the project was
rocketing along really smoothly
all the crew were really enthusiastic
about the film
in the end though falkenstein's project
was destined to end up as little
more than buried treasure over the last
decade
walt disney animation studios has become
much more comfortable with the idea of
producing sequels
back in the day only a handful of disney
animation movies such as the rescuers or
fantasia
landed follow-up projects in recent
years however the studio has released
new installments of some of its biggest
hits
including frozen and wreck-it ralph one
modern disney animation hit that didn't
score a sequel though was tangled
this is in spite of the film proving to
be a resounding financial success
and taking in a massive 585 million
dollar worldwide box office hall
so where is the sequel according to
producer roy connolly
the thought of doing another tangled
movie has actually crossed a few minds
in fact the original film's creators
even went so far as to discuss
what kind of story could be explored in
a perspective part two
while brainstorming ideas for a
follow-up however they came to one
undeniable conclusion did i ever tell
you i've got a thing for brunettes
[Music]
as conley explained to den of geek her
hair was gone
there you go without rapunzel's magical
hair
writing a tangled two seemed pretty much
pointless
still this doesn't mean more stories
can't be told in tangled's world
short form sequels have emerged in the
last decade such as tangled ever after
and the animated tv show tangled the
series
but a feature-length tangled sequel just
isn't something walt disney animation
studios seem able to straighten out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]